hey youtubers is Charlie so this week on
Doctor Who we totally got another game
of Thrones crossover and we also got to
meet Danny pink just like in my first
episode I'm gonna do my top 5 moments
then post as many of the references as I
could find and then my review but if
you're just finding me for the first
time I'm doing a weekly series 8
giveaway all you have to do to enter
that is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video so careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen the episode
yet but here are my top 5 moments it's
all wait just a sec okay ready here we
go number 5 coal Hill School is a big
destination I'm totally loving the meta
thing that's going on with Capaldi and
coal Hill School he and Moffat are
weaving a lot of first doctor things
into the show call the school obviously
being one of those the school itself has
always been featured in the series a lot
but I feel like there was such a first
doctor vibe coming from this episode
specifically after that the second
episode of the first doctors run was the
Daleks and obviously this episode was
into the Dalek so you see Moffat is
intentionally making us think about that
first season of Doctor Who I'm actually
wondering that's gonna tie in with the
Missy plot and the arc of series 8 there
will be references from all across
Doctor Who so don't just limit yourself
and looking for things from the first
doctor's run
anytime we revisit something for the
first time though during series 8 think
about the first time that character or
monster appeared there will be a lot of
new stuff though it's not all about just
revisiting classic stuff even though
Capaldi is you know fixing mistakes in
the past but number four the doctor
returns with coffee I love how it felt
like Clara bumping into him in the
closet happened directly after they
walked off screen in episode 1 like he
told her to wait a sec she turned around
BAM three weeks later he's back with the
coffee don't you just wonder what he did
during that three week period like what
he does when he goes away and says he'll
be right back and then shows up weeks
later it was a nice callback to Amelia
pond in that series five opener Moffat
used the be right back joke a lot during
Matt Smith's run so I'm not expecting to
see it in every episode of series 8
there will be a lot more Matt Smith
references but I'm expecting to see less
and less as we get on there's always the
danger of making a new doctor a complete
amalgam of the previous doctors so far
though I've been really happy with the
ratio of new Capaldi stuff to classic
doctor references but number three
welcome to heaven Missy is back isn't it
funny how journey blue woke up in the
TARDIS at the beginning and that other
soldier woke up in
heaven at the end of the episode so
notice the transition between each of
those locations both times it looked
very similar the doctor materialized the
TARDIS around journey blue usually
that's how they save someone whatever he
doesn't pull them in the front door
it makes me think more about the Missy
TARDIS Rani theories like Missy being a
personification of the TARDIS if that
were true she would have the same powers
as a TARDIS she'd be able to materialize
around someone if she's the Rani she'd
have a TARDIS of her own or access to
Time Lord technology but regardless of
who she is or who you think she has I've
seen a lot of dark Guardian theories too
she has access to the same level of
technology as the Time Lords which makes
me feel like her plot will tie in with
the finding Gallifrey plot don't you
just feel like heaven could be a room
inside a TARDIS I just love how sinister
that is but being inside a TARDIS would
be like being inside heaven it would be
a lot of fun what it seems like is
happening though is she's either
collecting the dead or collecting
lifeforce of collecting Souls there were
some spoilers for brave sides and
Cybermen in the finale so I'm not gonna
talk about them too much here but if you
want to comment on it just be sure to
use spoiler tags but on to number two
meet Danny pink so many things going on
here you have all the coal Hill School
first Doctor callbacks to Barbara right
near Chesterton then on top of that he
was also confirmed as an official new
companion I don't know why the BBC
waited so long and officially confirming
him as a companion because when they
made the announcement that he had been
cast all the language pretty much said
companion I love that he's ex-military
and pretty clearly suffers from
post-traumatic stress
Sherlock Watson anyone this makes me
feel like you know once he does become a
full-time companion the who Locke
references will be off the charts I'll
talk more about the Danny pink Peter
Capaldi who Locke 5 in my review but who
lot is happening and its name is Danny
pink the thing that really surprised me
was his relationship with Cara I didn't
expect them to ship them that fast but I
do totally love it and the way they jump
forward and backward in time when Claire
was trying to get Danny to ask her out
was so much fun she is clearly the boss
of everyone so there a couple important
red flags to watch out for in some of
their conversations first did you catch
when Clara joked about Danny crying
pretty clearly a reference to his PTSD
like Watson before he met Sherlock in
series 1 I feel like PTSD is gonna be a
running theme especially when he boards
the TARDIS then we have to add to that
doctor is not a huge fan of soldiers and
he is very clearly a soldier then that
moment at the end when Danny said I
thought you had a rule against soldiers
obviously a call back to Matt Smith
being the crazy warrior that the silence
was trying to kill in series 6 & 7 and
then all the darkness the Capaldi was
exhibiting in this episode which of
course leads me to my number-one moment
the doctor would make a good Dalek this
has always been a recurring theme in the
new Doctor Who series the doctor is just
as bad as the Daleks sometimes the line
is lifted directly from a Christopher
Eccleston episode so you know high fives
for Ninth Doctor callbacks he
essentially was like the post-traumatic
stress doctor too you know someone who
escaped the time war and was just trying
to deal with the psychological
after-effects I feel like he and Danny
pink are gonna have a lot in common in
that sense so expect the episodes to
play on that theme whenever he boards
the TARDIS automatically though the
episode was all about Capaldi testing
the theory you know can someone change
their true nature Daleks are evil
personified or they're supposed to be
and can never be good and I think the
doctor hates a lot of that darkness
inside himself so he's wondering is it
possible for him to change his true
nature the whole para a my good man was
a perfect runner for the Dalek turn good
story but let me know what was your
favorite moment and do you think that a
Dalek could turn good I mean obviously
it's pretty clear the episode wants us
to think that it can so moving along
here's a couple of the big references
and easter eggs I saw during the episode
if there were any that you saw please
add them in the comments so first off
was the awesome Empire Strikes Back
asteroid chase then the soldiers name
was journey blue kind of being a
reference to TARDIS blue at least I
thought she traveled in the Aristotle
which I feel like was a subtle reference
to fires of Pompeii it makes me think
that there's gonna be a fire to pompeii
reference in each episode of series 8
which I'm totally cool with then that
crazy military base reminded me of the
Torchwood from the David Tennant years
like when Torchwood was super hardcore
and dark then we have our Game of
Thrones crossover with Dolores Edie
somebody be sure to alert Jon Snow
someone has abandoned their watch the
Dalek theme in the episode was a nice
callback to the first doctor second
episode titled the Daleks there was also
a lot more references to Skaro and the
first time the doctor saw it which
happened in that first doctor's second
episode
jumping forward in time then flying down
those waterslide tubes of goo made me
think of beasts below which was Matt
Smith's second episode tricking
themselves down into the Dalek kind of
reminded me of fantastic
it was just like a really old movie from
the 70s Clara meeting Danny pink was a
total call back to the first time Ian
Chesterton and Barbara Wright met even
their costumes look very similar to the
original ones then we have all the
Watson Sherlock references and Danny
Pink's background and Capaldi's
personality that's only probably gonna
get dialed up in future episodes which I
am also totally cool with pink even had
his collar turned up like Sherlock I
mean obviously Capaldi is gonna be the
Sherlock in that equation but you get
the idea
speaking of coal hill though did you
notice the similarities in Capaldi's
blackboard and all the whiteboards at
the school it's like Moffat is taunting
us with spoilers that are just out of
focus and that we just don't quite
understand yet it's like we'll get to
the end of series 8 everything will be
explained and off it'll be like see I
put it in front of your face in that
first episode then we have the doctor
mind meld the biggest one that comes to
mind in recent memory was the mr. clever
one during nightmare and silver but
really the big one was Davros a speech
from series 4 you know I see Beauty I
see divinity but feel free to add any
other references you saw in the comments
below I'm sure there were a ton that I
missed overall I gave the episode a
solid a I enjoyed the episode more than
the premiere the story moved way quicker
up obviously of course the episode was
half as long I feel like 40 to 42
minutes is perfect for a Doctor Who
story but in terms of sets and story
locations I totally love the co-host
school is a big thing on the show again
Danny pink is gonna be a big part of
that but in general like I think he's
gonna be a lot of fun I haven't seen any
of Samuel Anderson's earlier work but I
love the way he was able to go from
really dark you know crying about
killing people to being super funny just
banging his head on the desk so if Danny
pink is gonna be really fun is like this
Clara I'm really wondering what he's
gonna be like as a companion I feel like
it's gonna be a lot of fun in terms of
crazy visuals I feel like you know being
inside the Dalek was probably the most
exciting thing I totally do not mind
that Moffat revisits a lot of old stuff
as long as it provides a new perspective
and this obviously of course did that
and in the end I loved how the doctor
answered his own question like I feel
like he does that a lot like the doctor
asked really big questions and just ends
up answering them to himself like he's
constantly having a conversation with
himself regardless of who he's talking
to I think the idea that the Dalek could
turn good is really optimistic for
Capaldi's run you know he's going to be
super dark but he's going to remain true
to his mod
never cruel never unkind always a healer
I feel like the most fun quote though
was when he said I'm going to do
something amazing promise we have to
remember that the finale is supposedly
all about broken promises broken trust
which feels like a clue for Missy that I
just don't quite understand yet all in
all I love the way that Capaldi's
personality is developing I feel like
we're still a little too early in series
eight to really get a sense of forward
he's like it took me all of series 5 to
wrap my brain around Matt Smith I am
really interested to see if the trend of
me liking each new episode more than the
one before continues episode 3 is robot
of Sherwood that's the one that Mark
Gatiss wrote I totally don't expect that
to happen it's almost impossible for
sure to completely one-up itself each
time but let me know what you thought
about all the classic ooh references and
what do you think about the Danny pink
Sherlock vibe and how it's gonna play
out on the show so I will be posting a
bonus video and a Q&A tomorrow so please
ask all of your questions in the
comments since I'm posting it tomorrow
you guys should have a ton of time to
rewatch the episode and think of more
questions normally I'd also post bonus
videos before episodes there but I'm in
the middle of moving apartments so I'm a
little bit behind so that's why all this
looks you know super different just to
answer questions about the giveaway for
any new people who have never seen it
before as long as your subscriber you
can just leave a comment on my Doctor
Who videos then when I post Q&A videos
I'll randomly pick someone out and just
give them an Amazon gift card it's
really simple and it's open to
international people so in case you
haven't seen it yet Steven Moffat
basically did a synopsis of his own for
each episode in series 8 I did a video
for it I'll add a link in the
description but right now you can click
here to get that bonus video that I'll
post later tonight and you can click
here to get the Q&A video thank you so
much for watching I'll see you guys
tonight high fives
you